welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Spider-Man
across the spider-verse a heartbreaking
and stunningly animated sequel to 2018's
into the spider-verse the movie filled
with Easter eggs cameos and incredible
attention to detail I'm gonna break this
movie Down frame by frame to point out a
ton of details that you might have
missed and I Revisited and broke down
the 2018 film for dozens of new details
and I hosted a live stream of across the
spiderverse in the Deep dive channel so
subscribe to the Deep dive and support
us with a Miles Morales Multiverse dive
shirt over at nerd riot.shop and uh whoa
hey look at that I'm already wearing it
right now I'm gonna wear this shirt
until I'm bleeding for my armpits okay
over the opening glitching logos for
Sony Columbia Pictures and Marvel there
is a brief miles from its name tag in
the 2018 film and he slapped on
everything and the Lord and Miller logo
has their Crest glitching to an
old-timey find mustache's ad with the
faces of The Producers themselves and as
with the 2018 film we actually open with
the approved by the comic code Authority
stamp which was put on Comics covers in
the 50s to reassure parents that the
comics wouldn't glorify crime or correct
their kids Minds we opened with When
Stacy this time framing this sequel has
as much her story as it is miles's she
says let's do things differently this
time telling miles a story third person
instead of the first person perspective
of the introductions of the first film
we see the selfie of Gwen and Miles that
she had on her phone in the last film
where you can actually see Peter B
Parker's legs stretched out between the
bus seats behind them this is on their
bus ride back the first time they really
connected and we see Gwen at drumming as
a member of her band The Mary Janes
setting up the wild drums solo music
that we hear over the closing minutes of
the movie as Gwen reassembles her new
band but during Gwen's solo here we see
flashes of Miles live from the first
film but also his upcoming battles with
Miguel and the spot so really this kind
of serves as an overture or a prologue
for the events to come this is Gwen's
home Universe Earth 65 and the animators
designed it to have a pastel watercolor
aesthetic it looks so great the paint
Strokes flood into each other a contrast
to the harder lines and boundaries of
the other realities on the subway miles
appears in the windows recalling the
2018 film with Stan Lee appeared as an
Angelic presence on passing train which
really hit hard back then because it was
just a few weeks after Stan died when
remembers before Miles when there was
her Peter Parker this Peter's Voice by
Jack Quaid and her flashback squint has
longer hair because this was before
miles stuck his hand to her hair and she
had to shave it Gwen flashes through
several meals that she'd Peter George
and Aunt May prayed before including one
that might be Halloween Peter dresses as
a dinosaur or a lizard when in a traffic
cone shirt George is a cowboy they're
all eating what is that Bagels this is
the cursed food that led to the spot and
in 2022 became the symbol for the
Multiverse with everything everywhere
all at once the bully that roughs up
Earth 65 Peter isn't Flash Thompson it's
Ned as in the spider Gwen Comics this
Peter becomes a lizard This Is Halloween
costume which we actually saw at the end
of Gwen's backstory in the 2018 film and
then we hear the voice of JK Simmons as
Jay Jonah Jameson reporting gotten Josh
Stacy is leading the Manhunt for a
smarter woman Simmons voices Jay Joe to
Jameson in several different realities
in this movie including the Lego
Universe later this guy is a freaking
Nexus being I'm telling you in the Stacy
family home Gwen is watercolor painted
blue and otherwise pink wash showing her
depression her room her sanctuaries also
blue like she is but her dad in Orange
and fuchsia wears a faded Visions
Gymnastic Academy sweatshirt suggesting
he might have once done cheer and
probably coached Gwen's acrobatics when
she was young he's a good Papa Gwen has
replaced her teal ballet slippers with
teal Chuck Taylors which she reportedly
got from Hobie Brown so I don't know
maybe they met before Gwen teams up with
Miguel and Jess in the spider society
when Gwen hugs her dad the blueness of a
room warms into pink watercolor
sometimes that's all it takes to change
your whole world above Gwen's door is a
sign reading protect trans kids and some
of you are mad now and if that pisses
you off feel free to stop watching I
don't need reviews spider Gwen webs up
or dad so uh how's the Manhunt for me
going yes she lowers her voice just like
miles does when he is masked and he
talks to his dad thank you for your baby
reading net now the vulture she fights
glitched here from Another Universe and
is named Adriano trumino instead of
Adrian tombs voiced by yorma tacon his
design and his sepia color tone and his
papery texture is based on Leonardo da
Vinci's sketches I like how when he
fires weapons Da Vinci scribbles and
instructions appear around him he lands
front of the Jeff Coons retrospective
exhibit this is a real exhibit at the
Guggenheim with balloon animal fixtures
made from stainless steel so basically
this is a Renaissance era artist
disgusted with post-modernism it's just
kind of an art joke he says
which translates to bye girl on the
screen but Gwen is saved by Miguel
O'Hara voiced by Oscar Isaac Spider-Man
2099 from earth928 who first appeared in
the 2018 film post credit scene Quinn
says I'm sorry who exactly are you
supposed to be isn't it obvious the blue
panther that's funny the Caped blue
sator yes blue panther reference to
Black Panther with similar claws caped
blue say to reference to Batman Caped
Crusader with similar brooding when he's
introduced with this comic it lands on
the stack of the comics of all the other
spider people we've met including all
the ones in the first film in the order
that we met them I just like how this
stack gets cumulative Miguel shames her
and the others are breaking the
Multiverse in the last movie and then he
says he started on Doctor Strange and a
little nerd back on Earth 1999-99 it was
Doctor Strange sounds like he maybe
shouldn't practice medicine yes Earth
199 999 has in the past been the
numerical designation for the MCU films
the shows but this was threatening the
question when Christine Palmer called it
616 and Multiverse of Madness I made a
video proposing that the MCU deserves
neither designation vulture reassembles
his wing and Miguel complains ah he's
got Hammer space and then we see an
editor's note text window popping up
defining it as an infinite extra
dimensional storage area for cartoon
Hammers and the like this is calling
back spider-ham's Mallet gift to miles
that he said could fit into any pocket
and not take up any space Miguel's
digital assistant is Lila voiced by
Greta Lee and she calls in Spiderwoman
Jessica Drew voice fight issue Ray her
yellow goggles match the shape of her
yellow eyepieces in the comics overall
she has the red black and yellow color
scheme like she does and yes she is
pregnant are you uh oh this we don't
know the sex yet my husband wants it to
be a surprise he's really corny but so
hot Jessica Drew is pregnant in the
comics leading up to the secret Wars
event and we do not meet her husband in
this movie presumably we will meet this
interesting character in the third movie
beyond the spiderverse coming next year
now when the vulture Falls he hits a
beam and then text says which is Italian
for night night and the three three of
them stop the helicopter from crashing
over the bystanders and one looks up at
it and says yeah I think it's a bank C
which is a callback the same exact sound
bite from the 2018 film the vocal Cameo
by post Malone yeah I think it's a
Banksy so Captain Stacy holds his
daughter at gunpoint and she unmasks
herself and the watercolor brush Strokes
smear down behind them just a cool way
of showing their whole world melting
Miguel and just invite Gwen at a Pity to
join the spider society and they lead
through these hexagonal portals hexagons
being a recurring shape in the MCU to
show Rifts through space and through
Dimensions so on to Earth 1610 Brooklyn
there's a food cart for mother Shuckers
I love it we follow this spot voiced by
Jason Schwartzman as he robs the ATM of
a bodega as he passes the bodega
register it reads game over so the spot
peels off one of his Oozy ink dots to
try to open a portal into this ATM but
he fails at one point he runs his own
hand to the side and he hurts his
knuckles but when he finally reaches in
notice how the 100 bill has a different
face than Benjamin Franklin thought this
might be director Joaquin dos Santos I'm
not exactly sure and in addition to
calling it an ATM machine the spot says
pin number which is also redundant since
n stands for number already now miles
Cuts away from this to recap the past
year the sequel I believe is set one
year and four months after the first
movie among the villancy fights appears
to be the Marvel villain LeapFrog he
says he hosted Jeopardy with categories
including arachnidiums Spider Sense and
Sensibility the Wide Web world and sweep
it we learn he endorsed baby powder
which is a callback to Peter B Parker's
advice in the first film to use baby
powder to get in and out of the suit
then he has to apologize in a YouTube
video and then we see miles adding to
his no expectations wall art mural all
of his friends from the 2018 film I love
how throughout this movie uncle Aaron
keeps coming back and back and back just
to remind us how important he is to
miles's life and set up the big twist in
the Final Act of this movie this fight
with the spot causes him to be late to
his parent-teacher conference flying
through portals in the background and
catching a goose which is a callback to
when miles got stuck to two pigeons in
the first movie and when they fly
through a blue portal following them is
another Bagel the symbol of Jonathan
Owens pain and his rage toward miles I
like how on Jefferson's bone text
history he wrote in all caps this is in
porkage and then he tried to correct in
fourth Kent and then finally gets it
right important miles fights with a spot
on a rooftop dodging his punches and
kicks at one point squeezing between a
punch and a kick essentially threading
the needle I love it miles patched the
spot on the head and red text reads good
cow because with all the spots he looks
like a Dalmatian named a cow and then
miles to the spot tumble into the foam
party Cafe having a literal foam party
with all the suds and Bubbles and that
goose squawking around this is the same
Cafe that Jefferson pointed out at the
beginning of the 2018 film the one with
the long line as the neighborhood was
being gentrified miles returns to his
Brooklyn Visions Academy dorm room where
his roommate remains ganke Lee who is
Miles buddy in the Ultimate Comics but
this character in the 2018 film had all
of his dialogue cut the characters now
been given lines and aged up in physique
and in voice I'm not your guy in the
chair
are those my Jordans I can't help but if
we're the same size guy in the chair a
reference to Ned Leeds Jacob
battleland's character and the MCU being
Tom Holland Peter Parker's guy in the
chair in Spider-Man homecoming and the
character of Ned in the MCU was really
just based off of Gaga Lee from The
Ultimate Comics now Genki Lee is voiced
in this movie by Peter song director of
Pixar's Elemental and is also the voice
of socks and Pixar's light year since
one of the co-directors of this movie is
kept Powers director of Pixar's soul I
like how they just keep it in the family
even though Peterson's Elemental is
going to be in direct competition with
across the spider verse in the month of
June of the box office the end of the
day all these animators just love and
respect each other I love it so Miles
finally arrives to the parent teacher
conference where his teacher is voiced
by Rachel Dratch miles's graves are
pretty good A and AP Physics that's my
little man and a B in Spanish what okay
I love how Jefferson tries to place that
cat themed desk ornament back together
but he fails the teacher's eyes just
start over but she just keeps talking
anyway it's kind of like an Iron Man 2
when Tony Stark obsesses over that thing
on his desk we learned that miles is
selling at AP Physics because like the
MCU Peter Parker it just helps any
Spider-Man to know physics and
trajectories and motion but miles B in
Spanish is met with outrage from his
Puerto Rican mother in which he steps it
forms a little Puerto Rican flag like
the sting of his mother's snap hits him
with the full might of his Puerto Rican
Heritage so Miles leads the guidance
counselor's office to rejoin his fight
with a spot which tumbles into Wilson
fisk's old alchemex collider site the
location of The Showdown of the 2018
film but it's now under construction
with this canopy made of reflected
panels reminding me of the Dome that was
constructed over the Chernobyl site
based on this part in our mess sign it
looks like alcamex are the ones actually
cleaning it up maybe they're continuing
to have some nefarious plans here like
you would think the government would be
like you guys aren't allowed anywhere
near this so the spot explains his
backstory and we see the Earth 42 spider
that bit miles but in its Earth 42
reality right before it left it was
going to bite alternate miles you can
see his hair in braids this is
foreshadowing the miles we see in the
third Act of the movie the big twist
telling us that in that reality it was
not going to be a Peter Parker who got
bit it was going to be a Miles Morales
the spot reveals that he was the one who
got struck with that hilarious Bagel
action word I love that they brought
this guy back so between Owen being the
source of spider 42 coming into 1610 and
Miles be the source of the bagel
incident they really did create each
other the spot trips and he kicks
himself in the butt through a portal it
looks like one of the pieces from debris
from the hex tiles kind of looks like
the rectangular USB drive from the first
film the trip mirrors miles tripping on
his shoelaces when he's running across
the rooftop for his jump test that is
what broke the USB drive and it kind of
was the embarrassment early in his Arc
that motivated the rest of his story so
similarly for the spot in this movie his
embarrassment here is really what
unlocks the next stage of his hero's
journey he finds himself in this Inky
whole realm where all the dark matter
has left his body creating all these
portals into the Multiverse the first he
looks into is this classic animation
Universe from the 1940s with Ben day
dots there's a woman in a black and
white polka dot blouse who hits him with
her purse her blouse matching the
pattern of his skin on the cinema
Marquee is a movie titled The Tall Man
coming soon Benny looks into the Lego
Universe calling back lord Miller's work
on the Lego movies we'll come back to
this one then he drops by Chinatown of
Earth 688 with Miss Chen from Venom and
Venom let therapy Carnage what do you
want I'm robbing you because I'm a bad
guy I love how unfazed Miss Chen is and
the brand of gum he steals we look
closely is Brock's venomint a reference
to Eddie Brock Venom and this
establishes Sony's Venom movies as
Universe 688 and their system of
organizing this spot looks at his hands
and says the power of the Multiverse in
the palm of my hand and not to Doc Ox
line in Spider-Man 2 in 2004 the power
of the Sun
in the palm of my hand which he echoes
in Spider-Man no way home the power of
the Sun in the palm of my hand back in
the Lego verse we see a text box which
is actually in the shape of a red Lego
brick labeling this earth13122 this
Peter Parker is voiced by Nick novicky
there's a Lego Jade Jonah Jameson in
this Daily Bugle office and they use JK
Simmons audio from the 2002 Sam Raimi
film when he says tomorrow morning
Spider-Man page one with a decent
picture this time so back at 16 10 miles
cannot sweat when he's carrying
kickboxes so he has to ride a crowded
train I don't like talking to why Peter
Parker trying to beats a time in
Spider-Man 2 and having to take the
elevator afterward miles says to hop off
the track to quickly zap the villain to
armadillo and then miles foils a thief
stealing Nikes he passes a bunch of
gawkers including this smiling dumbass
with glasses this is an aged up version
of that goofy student who Smiles at
miles in the Visions Academy in the
first film miles shows up late with the
cakes to the rooftop party having
changed into his basketball jersey
number 42 miles number the cakes are now
wrecked his heartfelt message is
spelling out just I'm not and then proud
Jeff and Rio complain that Genki calls
him by their first name so later when
Gwen does it they really cringe miles
refers to his friends Peter and gwanda
using Gwen's fake name that she gave him
in the first film miles returns to his
room where boxing gloves hang by the
door again reminding us of his boxing
lessons with Uncle Aaron there's also a
Michelle Obama Campaign sticker
suggesting that in 1610 she was the
Obama who held or at least sought public
office whereas before it was sunflower
the hot track of this sequel is
Hummingbird by Metro Boomin and James
Blake which miles chills out to here
remember the 2018 film ended with Miles
listening to post Malone's sunflower as
Gwen opened that portal over his bed and
asked if he has a minute and this scene
picks up with a similar moment just like
that but a year has passed since the
events of the first film and notice how
throughout this movie miles has been
aged up a bit a longer face he's a bit
taller and he has longer hair floating
around his room and a bunch of trading
cards with these red and white balls on
them these are for teriyakimon the 1610
version of Pokemon and when they're
sitting on the bed floating passes they
framed photo of miles with his uncle
Aaron his mentor figure who was shot by
Kingpin in the 2018 film and on Miles
shelf is an RC spidermobile which 1610
Peter had a life-size version of in the
2018 film and above that the specific
photo of Miles dad Jefferson and his
brother Aaron the Jefferson had as his
phone background and this exact photo
was framed in Aaron's apartment so this
is probably something miles found in his
uncle's apartment and moved to his
bedroom also on the shelf on the left
side of frame Lyles has this wooden
moose this is actually an Easter egg for
Lord and Miller's 2021 film Mitchells
versus machines this moose is a hugely
important item to the Mitchell Family in
that movie Gwen finds miles Sketchbook
iron man is lucky that she didn't see
any of the other drawings he probably
Drew of her in this but over on the left
he kept a bus ticket stub Hudson Valley
explorers Schenectady to Brooklyn
Central this was the bus ride home that
they took after Gwen saved them from
Olivia Octavius in the forest in the
2018 film so Miles has been scrapbooking
his relationship with her miles and Gwen
swing from construction crane to
construction crane just like Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man does at the climax
of the 2012 Amazing Spider-Man film as
they thread the needle between buses
notice how this whole block is just
colored in pink and teal Hues a way of
showing how Grant's colors are tinted
seen and shading this reality as their
influence spreads throughout it there's
this awesome point of view shot from the
truck driver miles swings on the right
side reflected in both mirrors and then
we turn to the right side mirrors as he
flies behind the truck and the
exclamation points from his scream chase
him just like the ah from his fall in
the 2018 film and the woo in the Final
Act I just love how miles stays behind
Gwen throughout this whole sequence
hiding his clumsy collisions and trying
to come off as more confident than he
really is really though just copying
Gwen's moves like hastily tying his web
to his ankle he tries to claim that he's
learned just as much as she has but
really he's just actively learning in
this moment from her they passed the hot
dog vendor and we see the action word
take on hot dog swipe but then miles
flips money to the vendor's chest he
goes closely this is an alternate
universe 25 bill I love this there's
just a kid who mindlessly licks the
window of the train with a big old smile
I think he's my favorite character in
this movie I can watch him on Loop this
is just so funny to me Gwen plants a
drone to spy on the spot's apartment
above it I love this is a billboard with
a bagel all of it always all over the
place the 1610 version of The Bagel
themed everything everywhere all at once
this movie's animator is clearly
acknowledging The Bagel parallel with
Jonathan own miles and Gwen look out of
the city sitting upside down from the
Williamsburg Bank building creating such
a Trippy of a great visual Gwen says in
every other Universe Gwen Stacy Falls
for Spider-Man
and in every other universe
it doesn't end well not only is she
referring to Earth 65 Peter's death as
the lizard she's also referring to the
universes where Gwen Stacy famously dies
in the death of Gwen Stacy Arc like we
saw with Emma Stone and The Amazing
Spider-Man 2.
back at the rooftop party miles and Gwen
flip some food and we see a can of grape
drink a nod to my favorite Dave
Chappelle bit a lot of black people
don't have the privilege of knowing
about grape juice because they have
great drink it's not the same formula
after Miles parents scare off Gwen we
get this heartfelt moment between miles
and his mother Rio the city they look
out on has incomplete sketch lines in
the distant background for the buildings
kind of in the haze of the city it's
just a really cool detail to suggest
that the Manhattan skyline is a part of
New York that Miles might not know as
well because really his home
neighborhood is Brooklyn ryoka Smiles
the advice that he really needs for this
whole film saying that she hopes her son
never lets any one of those big fancy
important places he's going to be in
tell him that he doesn't belong there I
think all of us can relate to feeling
like an imposter or a mistake or told
that we're not ready for the big leagues
and I think the third spider-verse movie
will prove that Miles anomalistic status
is actually the rule all spider people
should live by but it's just sad to
think that this moment with Rio is the
last time in this movie miles will talk
to his home reality mother in his chat
with Jeff earlier might be the last time
he talks to his dad from any reality
miles changed his wardrobe as he
descends a fire escape unzipping his
pants on the ground he'd seen a dog
walker and a dog and then awkwardly
re-zipping his pants back up okay then
to Owen's apartment we see from
photographs that he was once a
long-haired and bearded colleagues who
live Octavius his spider containers are
labeled Earth 42 this was the spider
that bit miles which is now deceased
because miles swatted and killed it but
there are other containers labeled 14512
that's Penny Parker's universe
333-90214 that is Spider-Man noir's
universe and 19925 this is a universe
supposedly written by a bot miles jumps
in after Gwen into the portal tunnel and
lands in Earth 50101 mumbatin a cross
between Mumbai and Manhattan from above
its geography looks like the island of
Manhattan but Greener and what we think
are the rivers are actually just the
city's lower levels the artists designed
my matin to keep going down and down and
down a contrast to 1610 and Nueva York
where the city just goes up and up and
up in mombaton instead of the trains
running on top of the tracks the cars
hang below from the rail above above
them throughout Manhattan you can see
signs for zomato which is a Restaurant
Group in India and here we meet pop
Privateer Private Car Spider-Man India
from Earth 50101 is voiced by Karen Sony
AKA Joe Pinder from the Deadpool films
he spends his web shooter on a spindle
like a yo-yo it looks so cool all the
action words in 50101 are in Hindi like
at one point we see thwip in Hindi and
when Privateer hits the spot in the back
of head it makes this Hindi word dadak
which translates to roughly bang or slam
and refer to the correct Smiles on the
common American chai tea mix up I love
chai tea what did you just say shy DJI
means D bro you're saying DD and I love
how miles is so distracted he spills the
tea it flows from the cup onto the table
also you could consider this a callback
to Miles correcting the spot on ATM
machine which is also redundant the m
stands for machine already so as these
three fight the spot imambaton we see
that his dark matter has filled in more
of his body so that he's gradually going
more from white to black throughout this
movie he makes it to the membatan
alchemix lab for its collider and Miles
tries to supercharge the barrier with
its new move that he's working on but
Hobie Brown arrives spider Punk voiced
by Daniel Kalia and he looks so cool in
this movie made up of different textures
of paper newspapers and posters but a
lot of it is in the speed at which he
moves in the 2018 film remember miles
was initially animated on twos which
means 12 frames per second instead of
the normal 24 frames per second giving
him a more staggered choppier Movement
by the end of the movie he was animated
on ones to show his Evolution into
smoother more confident swings in 24
frames per second homie in this movie is
deliberately animated I guess you'd say
on fours looks like six frames per
second really really choppy movement but
intentionally staggered a punk rock
poster come to life I love how this
reflects Hobie as a character a spider
variant who makes a choice of being out
of step with the other spider people
even more grounded in his home medium
Than Miles was it shows miles that
there's another way to exist in this
Multiverse and arguably more powerful
way because it forces the viewer to look
at every single pose that you strike
Hobie says I'm a role model
yeah hate the PM a bit of word play
there because wordplay is always very
common in the Cockney slang like later
we see him say Scooby-Doo meaning clue
but by PM yes he's saying he hates the
time of day in the afternoon but also he
hates the PM as in the Prime Minister as
a punk rock music scene in the UK grew
out of anger largely at Prime Minister
Margaret Thatcher geology is a 22 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognizing Men's Health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire in GQ
their products are built around just a
handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz geology will create a
simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
challenges co-wash and their deodorant
are just so great and I use them all the
time right now they're offering a
special offer for a skincare sampler
pack and geology skincare stuff is in a
league of its own geology's line of
skincare products can help you fight
acne reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles
combat dark or puffy under eyes have
smoother hydrated skin and Target signs
of aging there's never been a better
time to try geology than right now for
limited time use code rockstars100 to
get 100 off your personalized 30 days
skincare sampler set all you have to
cover is the 495 for shipping what a
deal on top of that new Rockstar's fans
get an exclusive bonus offer of up to 50
off on an additional skin hair and body
product of your choice when you add it
to your trial click the link in the
description or go to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started the spot activates the
collider infuses with the dark matter
and Miles Consciousness briefly overlaps
with Jonathan owns he sees the black and
white future of owns plans to absorb all
of reality and cause the deaths of
police captains with inspector Singh
gayatri's father and miles's dad Captain
Morales flickering back and forth as
they rush to save a kid so when miles
saves Singh in his mind he's saving his
own dad but both are considered Canon
events that Miguel O'Hara wants to play
out the alcox building collapses
reigning Rebel all over the City in the
forward leap into action Privateer sees
Gayatri on a double decker bus on the
bridge recalling MCU Peter Parker's
girlfriend MJ in a double decker bus on
Tower Bridge and Spider-Man far from
home in the MCU everyone ends up getting
saved it's an awesome scene but miles
disrupting the Canon event of Inspector
Singh's death causes dark matter to
consume the city Jessica Drew arrives
with the team to contain it she takes
the rest back to Nueva York Earth 928
spider Society HQ and I just love the
reveal that initially it's all upside
down with Miles and the rest on the
bottom side of the elevator lift it's an
interesting directional inversion of
that great moment in the 2018 film where
Miles Dives but they invert the shot to
make it look like a triumphant rise here
it's the opposite miles is technically
rising and going up the skyscraper but
because he's upside down it feels like a
descent into hell because this is not a
good place where miles is going but hey
we get to meet a ton of spider things
the animators say they created 280
spider people for this movie we've
already met a dozen or so but the
majority of ones in this HQ are really
just non-specific variants of different
shapes and suit designs I'm just going
to cover these specific references to
ones known from the comics and other
media so as they arrive we meet Malala
Windsor spider UK from earth835 She's
voiced by Sophia Barclay she says anyone
spout the spot and Jess gets annoyed and
asks if anyone else's jokes and we've
seen yellow text boxes showing everyone
else's jokes say Spot Run x marks the
weird looking bad guy did you say quip
or flip we need to run a spot check he
could be in any hole in the world puns
are my weak spot he's probably hiding in
some hole in the wall hey way to put us
on the spot mate this search is starting
to Peter out I hate it and as the camera
Glides through the main hall of the HQ
we pass the black and yellow spider
armor Mark II sitting on the left there
then a steampunky looking one with these
extra appendages this is Mabel Riley
lady spider from Earth 803 there's a
traffic cop Spider-Man and then there's
a bombastic bag man we'll talk about him
a little bit later then on the walkway
miles passes the spider armor Mark III
and then they pass Peter parked Carr of
earth53931 and then dropping into him
spider side of Earth 616 this is a thick
boy clone of 616 Peter also the last
stampeder Parker of Earth 312500 this is
the Peter with a high collar jacket who
gets killed in The Last Stand run and
exists alongside Ezekiel Sims then Peter
of earth13122 that's the Lego Universe
that we saw earlier can actually see the
little Lego man sitting on top of the
windshield there and then tarantula of
Earth 1610 a 16a being a side Universe
to Miles Universe of 1610 then they meet
the Moody and dramatic Ben Reilly
Spider-Man aka the Scarlet Spider from
Earth 94 voiced by Andy Samberg it's
mentioned here that he's a clone because
yes he is from the clone saga and yes
he's got a lot of baggage then they made
the web Slinger a cowboy Spider-Man from
Earth 31913 voiced by Taryn killem and
his horse Widow who's also in a mask
Lila takes them on the tour of all the
multiversal anomaly villains who have
been captured she mentioned several doc
Ox a Mysterio also a Mis stereo and then
a video game guy section in between them
is the Insomniac Spiderman of Earth 104
eight that's the universe of the PS4
games and he asks are you talking to me
and it's the voice of Yuri lowenthal who
voices Peter in those Insomniac games
there's an interesting villain named
typeface who says go to helvetica in the
2018 movie they changed all the New York
City public transit signs from the
helvetica typeface that it's in in the
real world to Ariel which Microsoft
introduced in the early 90s as an
alternative to helvetica so this might
just be an inside joke with these
animators they might just really hate
helvetica and prefer Ariel I could tell
you someone who writes all my scripts in
Ariel for YouTube Ariel is much nicer
because it takes up less space on the
page so that might be it then Lila
mentions an interesting Craven a boring
Rhino and then oh my God a Prowler a
cameo by Donald Glover in live action
Hobie claims he was the one who caught
him himself and Glover says I slipped
remember Glover played Aaron Davis in
the live-action MCU in Spider-Man
Homecoming in 2017 and in that movie he
referenced having a nephew who lives in
that area and in a deleted scene calls
him miles Glover also came out in the
2018 spider-verse film from his scene in
NBC's Community when Troy wears
Spider-Man p JS it's possible that this
could be the same Aaron from the MCU
just years after homecoming it is just
wild to see a live-action character
sharing the screen with animated ones
like Mary Poppins or who frame Roger
Rabbit and it increases the likelihood
that this series in the next movie May
introduce a live-action Miles Morales
who will be in the MCU and in the Sony
verse miles meets Margo Kess AKA spider
bite from Earth 22191 voiced by a man
less Stenberg she is a digital Avatar
and her physical body is back at home
where she has a poster we are Incognito
with a guy Fox logo an ultimate version
of the hacker group Anonymous all these
anomalies are sent to the go home
machine which comes back later but Margo
States here that it's based on DNA which
is important on their way in to see
Miguel Hobie rips a piece of tech out of
the wall joking I bet this doesn't do
anything but it sets up how later he's
able to engineer his own Multiverse
watch for Gwen to use like notice as
they continue to walk through he keeps
swiping more and more stuff to use for
it around Miguel's lab are futuristic
versions of tech from villains Miguel
has defeated by the year 2099 including
the claw of a Prowler the arms of Doc
Ock and the glider of green Goblin
showing how he must use scraps of their
Tech to continue building his technology
miles tries to connect with Miguel's
operating him empanadas but Miguel
throws the food back in his face and he
responds and a Kurt's more technical
Spanish Than Miles folksier Puerto Rican
Brooklyn slang Peter B Parker returns
along with his new baby daughter Mayday
Parker who has a baby day pass telling
us that Jessica Drew gave miles a
wristband that's normally for babies so
Miguel launches into his big explanation
first depicting all of reality as a
glowing white Vine with branches imagery
that I think is made to look just like
the sacred timeline of the MCU which
split into a Multiverse at the end of
Loki and is now a messy web last seen
the post-credits scene of Ant-Man that
was quantum Mania it's clear that this
movie is trying to establish the
animated spider versus part of the
live-action Marvel Multiverse from the
MCU but over this white Vine straight
red lasers beam out to represent these
spider-verse Miguel O'Hara refers to
this as a web of life and Destiny which
is the term in the comics where as he
says here arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse the nodes represent Canon
events and in the first one we see six
different Comics moments when a spider
bite occurred and including an early one
where Peter's wearing the yellow vest
behind that the right are various
moments Peter and MJ connect including
Kirsten Dunst Mary Jane Kitts and Toby
Maguire Peter in the Rain from the 2002
film then to the left the next nodes
that Miguel refers to is very very bad
shows six moments the Venom symbiote
overtook Eddie Brock in the comics it's
fascinating that Miguel categorizes the
creation of Venom as a Canon event in
the life of every spider person to me
this kind of feels like Sony's trying to
make venom as important as possible to
their spider-verse franchise which also
be kind of weird because they're too
been a movie so far removed the
Spider-Man step from the Venom origin
but going forward the implication here
seems to be that every Pier miles Gwen
or whoever will spawn a symbiote and
Rich rival that will plague their lives
then Miguel takes us through what I'm
gonna call death alley all the mentor
figures that the spider people have lost
miles sees a projection of his loss of
Uncle Aaron from the first film and
Miguel singles out recalls event ASM 90
which is a nod to The Amazing Spider-Man
number 90 in which George Stacy goes to
save a kid we actually see the same
Comics art of those panels here during
Spider-Man's fight with Doc Ock that and
ends up taking George's life I believe
it's 31 issues after this Amazing
Spider-Man 121 that is the death of Gwen
Stacy's daughter miles turns over to a
parallel moment a projection of Andrew
freaking Garfield Peter Parker crying
over the body of Dennis Leary Captain
Stacy from 2012's Amazing Spider-Man
film when George was killed by
recycling's version of the lizard Dr
Connors and again since all these Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield moments
connect to the MCU by association this
animated Spider-Man film is giving us a
codified understanding of how the spider
verse is all connected including to the
MCU Miguel confesses that he tried to
bypass a candidate of his variance death
in a reality so that he could be happy
in a reality with his daughter Gabriella
but eventually that reality erased
around him this may remind you of the
logic of what's called absolute points
and what if Episode 4 over in the Marvel
world but just sounds like different
terms for the same kind of idea Peter B
Parker explains the necessary loss of
Uncle Ben and in one node portal we see
Cliff Robertson Uncle Ben dying from the
2002 Sam Raimi film and Toby McGuire
Peter Parker crying over him but to the
right of that is the animated
Spectacular Spider-Man the one voiced by
Josh Keaton in the moment his Uncle Ben
died and then on the far right is Uncle
Ben's death from the cutscene to the PS4
game Josh Keaton actually joins the
other spider people in this intervention
saying I know it's hard but it's the
truth Miles when Miguel traps miles in
his red energy field Hobie holds out his
hands Palms calling back his advice to
Miles back in my baton to use the Palms
instead of the fingertips and so when
miles listens to him and blasts out of
the cage and all the other spider people
chase after him hobie's like not I'm out
and he leaves back through a portal and
tosses his watch behind I'm telling you
as we look ahead Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse Bobby Brown is a very
important character and a potential
mentor to Miles Morales that none of the
other characters are so Miguel alerts a
spider Society in this cafeteria one of
them's reading a newspaper with an
opinion page headline are cats man's
best friend they all break into groups
of three recreating the pointing meme
from the post-credits scene in the 2018
film which of course was repeated in the
live action Spider-Man no way home I
just love the idea that three is kind of
a magic number for these fighter people
to stump them into confusion like this
the group closest to us includes the
white logo PS4 game Advanced suit
Spider-Man and next to him is Spider-Man
Unlimited from the late 90s animated
series and then entering sector 4 is
this dude do I uh have web on my face
what's still this is Spider-Man 2211 AKA
Max born from Earth 9500 an associate of
Miguel O'Hara in the 90s comics and
Miles clings to his back kind of like
Aladdin does with that bodybuilder when
he flees the guards in the chase
sequence of that movie he falls down and
they're piling onto him like white blood
cells one of them definitely the gray
armored spider armor Mark 1 and then
spider cat who coughs up a web furball
on his face and notice how spider cat's
Gizmo is latched to its tail miles says
which is a call back to Peter B Parker
when they meet the other three eccentric
spider people in the 2018 film this
could literally not get any weirder it
can get weirder and then there's
a spider Rex when he flips it's t whip
miles gets hit by chibi Spider-Man the
really small one and then by spider
monkey then the web Slinger Cowboy
Spiderman for the wild west universe and
the ultimate animated series he fires
bullets from his revolver miles and web
Slinger end up in a Clint Eastwood style
duel the frame goes to a 293-1 effect
ratio like it does in westerns and Miles
gets a quick draw with a sweat and then
we get this moment I looked at my uncle
and ah let me guess he died
I love it on the walls of this therapy
office is an ink plot test that
naturally to us into all these
characters looks like a spider there's
also a diploma from ditko University and
not to Spider-Man co-creator Steve ditko
and it names this therapist Spider-Man
Ezekiel Sims who is the old man
Spiderman from the comics so since he's
the oldest of them he probably is the
wisest and has most therapeutic wisdom
to be able to give them Peter B Parker
asks Miguel to take a photo of he and
mayday's first Chase together Miguel
blows mom but Mayday whips the button of
the phone to take the selfie during the
chase miles slides into the legs of
Flash Thompson Spider-Man aka Captain
spider he wears the Letterman jacket
miles swings ahead of the bombastic bag
man this is from the comics when Peter
gets stuck in the Fantastic Fours Baxter
building has to borrow one of their
suits and wears a brown paper bag over
his head to disguise himself when miles
twists a bag around on his head you can
see the CMYK Ben day Dotson has outlined
staying the same size we also of course
see Spider-Man for the manga verse miles
pushes him away miles gallops on the
horse Widow pass the anomalies who cheer
him on while booing Miguel and the
others miles takes web Slinger's hat and
stuffs it in the face is spider wolf
then miles past his Charlotte Weber the
sun spider who is ehlers Dunlow syndrome
that affects her joints and connective
tissues so she uses a wheelchair and
crutches she's voiced by Danielle Perez
the 1967 Spider-Man from the Animated
Series returns from the 2018 movie post
credit scene voiced by yorma tacon and
then miles runs through a kind of danger
room with past Villains The Sinister Six
from the 90s animated series we see doc
Ox shocker goblin and the rest then
miles Dives out of the skyscraper a
cyborg Spider Woman follows along with a
Canadian Spider Woman with a hockey
stick that chippy Spider-Man rides miles
drops into underworld in wave of York
and Peter p Parker tries to get him to
hold Mayday saying miles is a reason he
had a kid reminds us of that moment in
the 2018 film when remember Peter B
Parker had split up with his MJ because
he didn't want to have kids but upon
meeting miles and seeing him kick ass he
realized wait do I want kids now Miguel
chases miles on the skybound bullet
train an incredibly animated fight at
one point in Miguel's lunge a frame
flashes from an animated storyboard cell
including some artist notes Imperial
Violet and crimson red this is what
instructs the artist which ink color to
to fill in the character with these
shades are the specific shades of the
red and indigo for Miguel's suit you'll
notice these kind of lines and notes
often hover around Miguel in its Tech I
just love how it hints at Miguel at
being a Tech head and a control freak
constantly trying to upgrade and upkeep
his own animation as he repeatedly has
to replug his techno-organic suit this
is what miles uses against Miguel here
placing his palm on his shoulder
overloading the suit giving him a
classic hey and then revealing he
intentionally lured all the spider
people high above the city so that he
could just leap off the train back to
the base Peter B Parker says I did teach
him that so I feel like a pretty good
Mentor referring to win Peter B Parker
in the 2018 film just jumped off the
ledge and fell into the collider beam so
that he could go home miles goes
invisible and sneaks past Margot he
scans its DNA and briefly you can see
the scan reading Earth 42 since it reads
the DNA of the spider that bit him so
the goho machine goes to work it's a
robot in the shape of a spider wrapping
miles up in a web of lasers Miguel tries
to pry in but when given the option to
reboot the system Margot decides at the
last second to just let miles go home so
miles tumbles into this red and green
Brooklyn where it rains it's a color
scheme that we haven't seen before so it
kind of hits us as really eerie and off
but it Bears a similar palette to the
1610 universe that Miguel Ben Reilly and
Jess go to making this a really
effective visual fake out back in 616b
Peter and MJ put Mayday to bed and MJ
says there's no Playbook on being a
parent you just have to make adjustments
at half time she feels like a Meta
Knight to this story's two-part
structure across the spider-verse ends
at halftime Beyond a spider verse being
the second half where Peter and Gwen now
have to make adjustments and put some
new players on the field Captain Stacy
tells us Dr Gwen that he's quitting
being a cop and he gives her the gadget
that Hobie built using text stolen from
Miguel on the screen it reads project
bootleg and for the strap he used a
Union Jack pattern band so Miles swings
through Times Square where all of his
villains past and present are haunting
him we see the giant hands the spot
reaching out to him but in Times Square
if you look closely you see W and W's
instead of M M's and Soca coca which is
a giveaway that this is not 1610 because
remember in his Universe it's coca-soda
instead of Coca-Cola Ben Riley camps out
outside miles room in 1610 but Gwen
takes them out and this is right as we
see miles arriving home so we naturally
just assume it's the same universe I
love when movies do this like my
favorite example is Silence of the Lambs
when you think clary's styling and the
rest of the FBI are at the same house
but then you realize the raid is
happening at the wrong place and Clarice
is at Buffalo Bill's house by herself
this also happens in The Fellowship of
the Ring when you think the ring wraiths
are about to stab the hobbits in their
beds but they're actually across the
street it always works on me and the way
they tease this out is so well done Rio
asks miles why he changed his hair she
doesn't remember giving him any advice
miles though has a speed bag by his door
now as in Earth 42 miles would be more
of an aggressive fighter also Earth 42
miles room has less toys and posters and
more stuff in milk crates around the
house there aren't really that many
photos of Jeff Morales just the mother
in the sun because it would have been
too painful to have too many photos of
him around miles reveals himself as
Spider-Man but Ryo doesn't know who it
is for a second we're just like oh she's
just a mom who doesn't really get it but
no there is no Spider-Man in this
universe miles demonstrates such a sad
little whip whip question mark and
there's a great match cut with Gwen
standing on the ceiling of Miles empty
room in 1610 cut two miles in Earth 42
with his mom and Miles finally figures
it out and hits us like a hammer uncle
Aaron walks through the door having
never died in this Dimension because
there's no Spider-Man and they go to the
rooftop the city is plagued with crime
on fire and the worst gut punch the
rooftop mural and place the Aaron
Memorial now has a memorial for Jeff
Morales in the upper corners of that
mural pacelli and Bendis for Sarah
Bocelli and Brian Michael Bennett's
creators of the Miles Morales character
miles gets ko'd by his alternate Prowler
self before he sees it coming his Spider
Sense never went off maybe because he
can't sense himself especially if that
bearing itself doesn't have spider
powers miles wakes up tied to Aaron's
punching bag the same one that he used
to work out on in the 2018 film and the
one miles tied Peter B Parker 2 Aaron
puts on an album Ain't No Love by a lion
Unleashed featuring Bobby Blue Band
Aaron punches the bag releasing a blast
of CMYK dots like all the ink was
slammed out of it we briefly hear the
voice of JK Simmons Trey Jonah Jameson
reporting crime from the TV as a younger
Prowler steps forward miles G Morales
whose hair is braided the same one we
saw back in the spot's backstory of the
spider that left Earth 42. our mile
space is lit red on one side blue on the
other mixing in the middle as Prowler
purple his fingertip manages to produce
a small spark on the Chain but he
doesn't have his full palm free
meanwhile Gwen reunites with Peter B
Parker and Mayday as we hear her drum
solo returning from the opening minutes
and we see the new band that she has put
together including Quinn Peter B Parker
Mayday Hobie Brown private to your
private car Margo kiss spider bite and
returning from the first film but not
saying anything Penny Parker spider-ham
and Spider-Man Noir and we end with Gwen
asking us the line you want in this
explains why the film opened the way it
did from Gwen's point of view a third
person account on what miles went
through telling us why she quit her band
saying let's do things differently this
time and why the opening images included
things that happened in Miles throughout
the film this was all Gwen's sales pitch
her recruiting Mission what she said to
every single one of these spider people
to get her to join her team to join this
Rescue Mission in this Brave step to
defy the spider's Society so yeah we
want in and go ahead and take my money
for Spider-Man beyond the spider verse
next year holy what a cliffhanger
and what a film please support our
growing network with a Miles Morales
Multiverse dive shirt and nerd ride dot
shot subscribe to the Deep dive channel
for deeper dives into the spider-verse
this week and subscribe to our third
channel the break room follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]